la distanciation sociale aussi.
Et sans plus tarder d'ailleurs,
je me tourne vers mes collègues
et amis dont je m'ennuie
beaucoup, beaucoup,
Bouchra Ouatik et Jeff Yates.
Salut! Ça va?
- Oui. Salut Alexis. Ça va toi?
- Salut Alexis.
- Oui, très content de vous
voir, même si c'est pas en chair
et en os, quand même, ça fait...
ça fait grand plaisir.
Alors, depuis un mois, on n'a
pas chômé, hein, depuis le début
de la crise, on est maintenant
à quoi, une quarantaine
d'articles publiés,
une vingtaine de capsules
vidéo tournées au compteur,
ça fait pas mal ça. Et ça part
en grande partie d'une quantité
hallucinante de courriels
qu'on reçoit jour après
jour ça, Bouchra et Jeff.
Alors, un petit mot d'ailleurs
sur cette abondance de
courriels, cette demande qui est
évidente de la population qui
cherche à avoir de l'aide pour
qu'on puisse départager le vrai
du faux. Alors, en mode
télétravail, comment
ça se passe, Bouchra?
BOUCHRA OUATIK
@bouchraouatik
- Bien, vraiment, les gens
nous écrivent, c'est du
jamais vu, on reçoit des fois
100, 150 courriels par jour.
Donc, si les gens se demandent
pourquoi on leur répond pas
un par un, c'est parce qu'on
reçoit énormément de courriels.
Et on voit dans ces courriels-là
que les gens sont submergés
d'informations que leurs proches
leur envoient. Parfois ils nous
disent : un membre de ma
famille, un ami a fait circuler
ça, je sais pas trop quoi en
penser, est-ce que c'est vrai?
On voit que les gens
sont inquiets parce que
le coronavirus, ça peut être
une question de vie ou de mort,
et donc les gens, quand ils
voient ces informations-là,
ils sont très inquiets que
ce soit vrai. Ils reçoivent
parfois des faux conseils pour
se protéger, ils savent pas
s'ils doivent les suivre.
Donc, vraiment, on ressent
beaucoup d'inquiétude dans
les questions que les gens
nous posent et on essaie d'y
répondre le plus rapidement
possible, là, en faisant
des articles.
- Des trois, Jeff, c'est toi
qui as le plus d'expérience en
la matière, là, quand on parle
de lutte à la désinformation.
Avais-tu déjà vu un tel volume
de fausses rumeurs, de fausses
croyances et de désinformation?
JEFF YATES
@Jeff_yates
- Non, jamais. J'avais jamais
rien vu quelque chose même
qui s'approche du volume
de désinformation qu'on voit
à propos de la COVID-19.
J'ai jamais vu autant...
j'ai jamais reçu autant de
messages à propos d'un seul
sujet. Et là, j'ai couvert
l'élection de 2016 aux
États-Unis qui nous a donné
l'expression "fake news",
et même là, on n'a jamais
rien vu de la sorte.
Bouchra disait tantôt qu'on
peut pas répondre à tous les
courriels, mais je veux assurer
tout le monde qui nous écoute,
on les lit tous. On s'est
fait un système de triage
où on collige toutes
les informations que les gens
nous envoient, on traite
les cas les plus prioritaires,
les plus potentiellement
dangereux ou les choses
qu'on reçoit le plus souvent.
Mais sachez qu'on a besoin
de vos courriels. Donc, même
si on répond pas, on a besoin
que vous nous disiez ce qui
circule, on a besoin que vous
soyez nos oreilles et nos yeux
sur le terrain pour qu'on sache
ce qui circule sur les réseaux
sociaux. Donc, votre aide a été
énormément précieuse pour qu'on
soit au courant de ce qui se
passe. Donc, continuez à nous
envoyer des courriels, c'est
crucial.
- Je te seconde là-dessus, Jeff,
sans contredit. Et je tiens
à saluer au passage des gens
qui ont été appelés en renfort
pour nous aider, étant donné
le volume de travail auquel
on fait face, Mathieu Gobeil,
Nicolas de Rosa, on les remercie
pour leur apport à ce travail
essentiel et crucial dans
le contexte actuel.
Alors, allons-y maintenant
pour notre tour d'horizon
de la semaine. Et c'est parti!
- Pas un chat.
Le gardien de sécurité, là,
il est venu me dire que
j'avais pas le droit de prendre
de photos ici.
Le parking est vide.
Pas un "osti" de chat
à l'hôpital. Puis supposément
que c'est ici, supposément,
qu'il y aurait beaucoup
de cas à Lasalle.
- Des images qui ont été
visionnées à près de 15 000
reprises, Jeff, des images
de salle d'urgence vide.
Et c'est assez pour que
certains y voient la preuve
de l'inexistence d'une crise
sanitaire.
- Bien oui, c'est un phénomène
qu'on voit en fait un peu
partout au monde. Ça a commencé
aux États-Unis, les gens ont
commencé à s'improviser
journalistes citoyens, à aller
dans leurs hôpitaux locaux et
filmer les salles d'urgence
qui sont vides. Et là, on dit :
"Regardez, on nous dit qu'il y a
une crise, alors qu'il y a
personne à l'urgence."
Et on a vu ça un peu partout
dans le monde, on l'a vu en
France, il y a eu des mots-clics
sur les réseaux sociaux pour
encourager les gens à aller
filmer leurs hôpitaux, on a vu
la création de groupes Facebook
pour partager ces images-là.
C'est sûr qu'en regardant ça,
ça peut avoir l'air... ça peut
soulever des questions.
Donc, on dit qu'il y a une crise
dans les hôpitaux, pourquoi
est-ce que les urgences sont
vides? J'ai parlé à Gilbert
Boucher, le Dr Gilbert Boucher,
qui est le président de
l'Association des médecins
spécialistes en urgence.
Et ce qu'il m'expliquait,
c'est que, dans le fond,
c'est prévu ça, ça fait partie
du plan du gouvernement du
Québec pour faire face à cette
crise-là. Donc, on a demandé
aux hôpitaux de maximiser
les ressources disponibles pour
traiter les cas de COVID-19,
et ça, ça veut dire détourner
certains services qui étaient
dédiés aux services d'urgence.
Donc, par exemple, on va pas
faire venir les gens à l'urgence
pour faire des suivis, on va
faire des suivis plutôt au
téléphone, on trouve d'autres
façons de faire des suivis
comme ça. Et ça fait partie
du plan, donc c'est une bonne
chose que les urgences soient
vides en ce moment parce que
ça veut dire que les ressources
sont disponibles pour un afflux
de gens malades avec la COVID.
Cela étant dit, aussi,
ce qui rentre aussi en compte,
c'est qu'il y a, bien, vous,
la population québécoise
suit très bien les conseils
de distanciation sociale,
donc on voit beaucoup moins
de visites à l'urgence pour
des petits cas de routine.
Donc, le Dr Boucher me disait
qu'on voit beaucoup moins de
cas... de visites à l'urgence
qui sont pas sérieuses.
Donc, les gens ont compris
qu'il faut pas aller à l'urgence
un peu pour n'importe quoi.
Puis le Dr Boucher me disait
aussi que parce que tout le
monde est confiné, ça change
le mode de vie de tout le monde,
donc on voit moins des accidents
ou des crises cardiaques ou
des choses comme ça parce que
les gens restent à la maison.
Donc tous ces facteurs-là font
en sorte que les urgences sont
beaucoup moins achalandées que
d'habitude. On parle à peu près
d'un taux de 60 % pour ce qui
est des hôpitaux de Montréal,
alors que c'est plus dans
le 100 à 110 % d'habitude.
Ça veut pas dire qu'il y a pas
de crise, ça veut pas dire
que la crise est exagérée,
il y a tout plein de facteurs
là-dedans, mais c'est plutôt un
bon signe, en fait, ça veut dire
que nos hôpitaux ne sont pas,
pour le moment, surmenés par
cette crise de COVID-19-là.
Donc, plutôt que de mettre de
l'avant des idées comme quoi
la crise est inventée ou quelque
chose, on peut... on peut saluer
les efforts de notre système
de santé et de la population
de rester à la maison.
- Exactement, dans le but
d'aplatir la courbe.
Et là, je ne répéterai pas
la gestuelle du Dr Arruda
pour ce qui est de la courbe.
On va maintenant parler de la
Chine, chers amis, parce que ça
aussi c'est un foyer important
de désinformation. On a pu
le constater jour après jour,
notamment les courriels que
vous nous avez fait parvenir.
Alors, dans le registre des
théories du complot, la Chine
est un incontournable pour
les conspirationnistes
qui développent pas mal
d'obsessions à ce sujet-là.
- Il semble que ce virus était
une décision du gouvernement
chinois en réponse à la perte
de la guerre commerciale contre
les États-Unis. L'objectif :
plonger le monde en récession.
Le scénario n'est-il pas clair?
- Bien, voilà un bon exemple
de ces types de théories
conspirationnistes qui
circulent. Beaucoup de courriels
au sujet de cette vidéo qu'on
vient de voir, cet extrait qu'on
vient de voir, qui est en lien
aussi avec des publications qui
vont dans le même sens et qui
laissent croire que la Chine
a créé ou si on veut téléguidé
la pandémie de toutes pièces.
Pourquoi? Pour le bien de son
économie, pour damer le pion
à ses concurrents, pour mettre
ses concurrents à genoux,
finalement. Alors, d'entrée de
jeu, pour qu'une théorie comme
celle-là tienne la route, bien,
il faudrait qu'il existe des
données qui indiquent clairement
que l'économie chinoise tire
profit de la crise. Eh bien,
c'est pas le cas, selon des
spécialistes que j'ai consultés,
notamment notre collègue
Andréanne St-Arnaud, journaliste
spécialisée en économie ici
à ICI RDI, et aussi Florian
Mayneris, qui est professeur
d'économie à l'École des
sciences de la gestion à l'UQÀM.
Ce qu'on voit en ce moment,
c'est que dès janvier, février,
l'économie de la Chine,
le moteur économique du monde
entier a été amené à zéro
ou pratiquement. Et ensuite,
ce qu'on a vu, c'est une
récupération très, très, très
infime des activités en Chine.
Il y a des bourses aussi qui
sont utilisées, qui sont
brandies en guise de preuve,
entre guillemets, que les
choses vont mieux en Chine,
contrairement à ailleurs
dans le monde.
On dit : "Regardez les bourses
chinoises, ça va super-bien
comparativement à ce qui se
passe ailleurs dans le monde."
Il y a des petites nuances
qu'il faut apporter à ce
chapitre-là, comme nous le
rappelait Andréanne St-Arnaud.
Dès le mois de décembre,
on le voyait qu'il y avait moins
d'envolées spectaculaires dans
les secteurs, dans les marchés
boursiers chinois. On voyait
qu'il y avait moins de
volatilité. Alors, quand
la crise est survenue, en plus
de ça, il y avait la fermeture
traditionnelle des marchés
boursiers pour le Nouvel An
lunaire, non pas 10 jours,
mais 13 jours cette année,
alors c'était complètement
fermé. Et pendant cette
fermeture, déjà le gouvernement
chinois, étant donné la crise,
avait annoncé des mesures
budgétaires et monétaires
pour calmer les choses
et calmer les actionnaires.
Ça a eu son effet sur les
bourses chinoises, ce qui
explique entre autres le fait
que ça va un peu mieux de ce
côté pour elles par rapport
au reste du monde.
Et quant à la reprise économique
en Chine, certains disent :
"Autre preuve que c'est un coup
monté. Bien, voyez, l'économie
chinoise roule à plein régime."
Eh bien, c'est faux.
Si on regarde juste le secteur
manufacturier, qui est un gros
morceau dans l'économie
chinoise, bien, on est
à 40 ou 50 % de production.
Écoutez, c'est simple :
si la Chine veut produire
à plein régime, faut qu'elle ait
des débouchés. Des débouchés,
il y en a pas, le reste de
la planète, l'économie de
la planète est pas mal
au ralenti en ce moment.
Et puis sur le fait que
la Chine aurait créé le virus
en laboratoire et aussi un
antidote pour y remédier,
bien, je veux pas trop
m'éterniser là-dessus,
ça a déjà été prouvé à maintes
reprises que ça ne sort pas d'un
laboratoire. Il y a des études
scientifiques qui prouvent très
clairement que c'est le fruit
de l'évolution naturelle,
et un vaccin, va falloir
attendre, quoi, de un an
à 18 mois avant que ça soit une
chose possible et envisageable.
La Chine encore en toile de fond
de cet extrait qu'on vient
d'entendre, Bouchra. En fait,
ce qu'on voyait, les faits
ce qu'ils nous disent, là,
c'est que c'est un extrait
du FBI qui annonçait
l'arrestation du Dr Charles
Lieber, qu'on voit ici sur ces
images d'archives, qui, selon
plusieurs conspirationnistes,
aurait vendu le coronavirus
à la Chine.
- Oui, donc il y a cette vidéo
qui circule, où on voit donc
un procureur américain qui dit
que cet homme a été arrêté.
On entend le nom de Wuhan,
qui est la ville où l'épidémie
a commencé. Donc, ça a l'air
suspect tout ça parce qu'il y a
des gens qui ont partagé cet
extrait-là, qui est réel,
qui n'est pas truqué, et ils ont
mis comme titre : "L'arrestation
du concepteur de la COVID-19."
En plus de ça, il y a une autre
image qui a circulé énormément,
qu'on nous a envoyée, où on voit
encore la photo de ce chercheur
américain, Charles Lieber,
et on dit : "Voici l'homme
qui a fabriqué et vendu
le virus du corona à la Chine."
Donc, qu'est-ce qui est vrai
là-dedans? Premièrement,
c'est vrai que Charles Lieber
est un chercheur de Harvard,
plus précisément directeur
du Département de chimie,
et qu'il a été arrêté
le 28 janvier dernier par
les autorités américaines.
C'est vrai que son arrestation
avait un lien avec la Chine,
c'est vrai qu'il y avait
un lien avec Wuhan. Mais c'est
là que s'arrêtent les faits.
Et tout le reste en lien avec
le coronavirus, ça, ça tient
de la théorie du complot,
parce que les accusations
réelles auxquelles cet homme
a fait face, elles n'ont aucun
lien avec le virus, elles n'ont
aucun lien avec la COVID-19.
En fait, c'est que cet homme-là,
ce chercheur-là, il a accepté
des fonds de la Chine dans
le cadre d'un programme qui
vise, un programme chinois
qui vise à recruter des experts,
des chercheurs de tous les
domaines pour qu'ils travaillent
au profit de la Chine.
Et selon le gouvernement
américain, ce programme-là,
son intention réelle, c'est
que la Chine puisse faire en
quelque sorte de l'espionnage,
donc recruter des chercheurs
américains pour voler des
informations sensibles et
les transmettre à la Chine.
Donc, c'est un programme que
le gouvernement américain
circule. Alors, ce chercheur
de Harvard, non seulement
il était recruté par la Chine
dans le cadre de ce programme-là
mais en plus il a caché le fait
qu'il était payé des dizaines de
milliers de dollars par mois par
la Chine. Et ça, c'est un crime
aux États-Unis parce que comme
ce chercheur reçoit des fonds
des autorités américaines pour
ses recherches à Harvard,
il est tenu de divulguer tout
intérêt financier étranger.
Il a caché le fait qu'il était
par la Chine, et voilà, c'est
la raison de son arrestation.
Et vous voyez que si vous
écoutez cette fameuse vidéo
qu'on entendait il y a quelques
instants du procureur américain
qui annonce son arrestation,
il n'est jamais question
de coronavirus. En fait,
ce chercheur-là, ce n'est même
pas un chercheur en virologie,
c'est un chercheur en
nanotechnologie, donc c'est
un chercheur qui ne connaît
finalement pas grand-chose au
domaine des virus, il n'a jamais
travaillé dans ce domaine-là.
Alors, voilà comment on a pris
une vraie histoire et qu'on
l'a... qu'on y a ajouté
des faux éléments, parce que
ce chercheur-là, ça s'adonnait
qu'il était entre autres financé
par une université à Wuhan,
mais là s'arrête le lien
avec le coronavirus.
- Ça c'est un pattern qu'on a
souvent vu, Jeff, Bouchra,
des gens dont l'expertise n'est
pas nécessairement en lien avec
le sujet dont ils parlent,
la COVID-19, en l'occurrence,
dans le cas qui nous occupe
pour une période d'un mois
maintenant. On l'a vu à bien
des reprises, c'est important
qu'on vérifie bien qui parle
et quelle est son expertise
réelle, n'est-ce pas?
- Oui, tout à fait. Donc, on a
vu énormément de vidéos de gens
qui se filment dans leur salon,
dans leur auto, et qui affirment
toutes sortes de choses à propos
du coronavirus. Certains ont
même l'air de savoir ce dont
ils parlent. Donc, certains
utilisent du langage extrêmement
technique, donnent même parfois
l'impression qu'ils sont
médecins. Toujours s'assurer,
là, c'est qui cette personne-là,
sur quelles sources
d'informations elle se base.
Donc, un bon truc, là, si vous
voyez une vidéo YouTube, allez
voir la chaîne YouTube parce que
souvent ça nous apprend beaucoup
sur la personne. Il y a une
vidéo très virale sur le
coronavirus qui a circulé, là,
depuis la semaine dernière.
Puis quand on allait voir
la chaîne YouTube en question,
bien, on voyait que cette
personne-là avait publié
des vidéos qui affirmaient
que la lune n'existe pas.
- Ah! Bon!
- Que la terre est au centre du
système solaire, des histoires
comme ça. Donc, ça donne une
meilleure idée de la fiabilité
de cette personne-là.
- Jeff, je me demandais bien...
- Et Alexis?
- Oui, je t'en prie, Bouchra,
vas-y.
- Pour compléter ce que Jeff
dit.
- Bien oui.
- Donc, que des gens qui
sont pas des experts parlent,
on constate aussi... souvent les
gens nous demandent qui sont les
gens qui créent les fausses
nouvelles. Et parfois c'est des
gens qui sont malintentionnés,
qui veulent créer la confusion,
donc ils vont inventer des
choses. Mais parfois, c'est des
gens qui pensent avoir raison,
qui pensent être de bonne foi,
parce qu'ils ont lu des études
qu'ils pensent être réelles,
mais ils les ont mal comprises.
Donc, la désinformation,
ça peut être accidentel,
ça peut être des gens qui sont
pas malintentionnés. Donc, il
faut se méfier, là, même quand
ça ne vient pas de quelqu'un qui
est forcément conspirationniste.
- Exactement, des gens qui nous
balancent souvent plusieurs
informations au visage lors
de ces longs monologues qui,
malheureusement, sont très
populaires en ce moment sur
YouTube. Jeff, je me demandais,
depuis le début, quand est-ce
que QAnon va embarquer dans tout
ça, le groupe conspirationniste
QAnon qui a fait son entrée avec
la question de la COVID-19.
Et ce qu'on entend à ce sujet-là
est assez particulier, merci.
- Bien oui, on a reçu beaucoup
de messages de la part de
lecteurs qui étaient un peu
confus par rapport à des
messages qu'ils ont vu circuler
sur les réseaux sociaux, parfois
des membres de leur famille leur
ont envoyé des messages qu'ils
ont vu circuler. Bon, deux
catégories de messages.
Un des messages disait qu'il
va y avoir un black-out de
l'Internet pendant trois jours
durant lequel Donald Trump,
le président américain,
va déclarer la loi martiale
et faire arrêter des centaines
de milliers d'Américains
supposément pour des rituels
sataniques et pour avoir prélevé
des substances dans des cadavres
d'enfants.
- Pardon?
- Il y a un autre message aussi
qui a circulé qui affirmait que,
bien, on a découvert des tunnels
avec 100 000 enfants, un tunnel
qui reliait le port de New York
à la Fondation Clinton qui
appartient à l'ancien président
Clinton et à sa femme Hillary
Clinton, et on dit que
le navire USNS Comfort,
donc le navire-hôpital qui a été
acheminé à New York pour faire
face à la crise de COVID-19,
on dit que, bien, en fait,
ce navire-là sert à traiter
ces enfants mal nourris
et maltraités donc qui ont
supposément été kidnappés
par la Fondation Clinton.
Donc, on nous a demandé...
Ce n'est pas qu'on y croyait
nécessairement, mais on nous
demandait d'où ça vient ça,
parce que ça sort... ça semble
sortir de nulle part, ça n'a
aucun sens. Pour le commun des
mortels, on lit ça, on se dit :
bien, c'est quoi le rapport
avec la réalité? Ça provient
d'une conspiration qui s'appelle
QAnon. Pour faire une histoire
longue un peu plus courte, c'est
une personne qui se prénomme...
qui s'est donné le nom Q,
qui depuis 2017 parle sur
les forums en ligne et affirme
être un haut placé dans
l'administration de Donald Trump
et dit que, dans le fond,
tout le chaos qu'on voit
dans la politique américaine,
c'est une mise en scène pour
que, finalement, Donald Trump
puisse reprendre le contrôle
du pays et jeter ses opposants
en prison. Donc, il y a toutes
sortes d'histoires reliées à ça,
souvent des histoires de trafic
d'enfants. On accuse tous les
opposants de Donald Trump d'être
des satanistes, de faire du
trafic d'enfants. Vous vous
rappelez la fameuse conspiration
Pizzagate qui a circulé pendant
l'élection de 2016, où on disait
que le Parti démocrate faisait
du trafic d'enfants dans une
pizzeria à Washington DC.
Bien, ça découle en partie
de ça et on a juste
continué à faire évoluer
ces conspirations-là.
Donc, faut faire très attention.
Ces conspirations-là,
ça provient des pires bas-fonds
de l'Internet. Et si on connaît
pas le contexte, ça peut avoir
l'air alarmant ces histoires-là,
mais c'est purement
des inventions de
conspirationnistes.
- Alors, ça, je le souligne,
c'est important de le rappeler,
chacun des sujets dont on vient
de parler depuis le début de
cette émission, Jeff et Bouchra,
bien, on les retrouve sous forme
d'articles sur notre page web,
c'est important de le souligner,
tout notre contenu, tout notre
contenu sous forme d'articles
se trouve là. Je vous invite
à vous y rendre le plus souvent
possible. Et en plus de
ces vérifications de faits
qu'on effectue jour après jour,
semaine après semaine, Jeff et
Bouchra, ce qu'on fait aussi,
bien, c'est regarder ce qui
se dit, ce qui s'écrit sur
la désinformation en général
un peu partout dans le monde.
Commençons donc avec ce qui
a capté votre attention cette
semaine. Si je commençais,
tiens, par Bouchra, sur la
Hongrie. Semble-t-il qu'il y
aurait des citoyens pourquoi,
pour des fausses nouvelles?
- Oui, bien justement, Alexis,
on en parlait au mois d'octobre
dernier à l'émission, on avait
parlé de pourquoi est-ce qu'on
ne rend pas le fausses nouvelles
illégales, c'est une question
que les gens se posaient ici.
Et ce que je t'expliquais à ce
moment-là, c'est que les pays
qui ont décidé de rendre les
fausses nouvelles illégales,
c'est loin d'être des
démocraties, c'est des pays
qui veulent en fait censurer
les critiques. Et là, la Hongrie
a franchi un pas important
le 30 mars dernier, le premier
ministre a décidé qu'il allait
diriger le pays par décret,
donc le Parlement lui a donné
les pleins pouvoirs pour
qu'il puisse diriger de façon
indéterminée le pays par décret,
sans l'accord. Ça c'est donc
pour mieux gérer la crise,
donc c'est l'argument avancé.
Mais ce changement-là en Hongrie
fait en sorte que dorénavant les
citoyens pourront être arrêtés
parce qu'ils auraient partagé
des fausses nouvelles sur
le coronavirus. Et ce dont
s'inquiètent les défenseurs
des droits de la personne,
c'est que les gens qui vont
se faire arrêter, ça risque
d'être, par exemple,
des journalistes qui dévoilent
que le gouvernement n'a pas
été transparent sur la crise,
ça pourrait être des citoyens
qui posent des questions,
des critiques, des gens qui
remettent en question le bilan.
Alors, ça risque de faire
très mal à la démocratie,
à la liberté d'expression.
Et la Hongrie n'est pas le seul
pays qui fait ça. On voit qu'aux
Philippines, il y a des amendes
très salées pour les gens qui
partageraient des fausses
nouvelles sur le coronavirus.
En Égypte, une journaliste
a été expulsée parce que,
dans un article, elle remettait
en question le bilan du
gouvernement. Donc, on voit
que la liberté d'expression
s'effrite sous prétexte de
bannir les fausses nouvelles.
Et il y a pas mal de pays
dans le monde, de pays assez
totalitaires, qui vont dans
cette direction-là.
- Bref, il faut se méfier de...
- Et aussi...
- Oui, oui, allez-y.
- Oui, donc je voudrais rappeler
aussi que, au tout début de
la crise, on avait vu un cas
vraiment flagrant, là, de ça,
on en avait parlé même
à l'émission. C'était un
ophtalmologiste chinois qui
avait été le premier à sonner
l'alarme fin décembre, il avait
dit : "Il y a un virus qui
s'en vient." Et qu'est-ce que
le gouvernement chinois a fait
à ce moment-là? Il l'a arrêté
et il l'a accusé d'avoir
propagé des rumeurs fausses,
mais on sait maintenant que
ce médecin-là avait raison et,
malheureusement, il est décédé
lui-même des suites de
la COVID-19.
- Oui, le Dr Li qui fait figure
de héros et de martyr aux yeux
de bien des Chinois qui, malgré
tout, ne croient pas ce que leur
sert le régime, c'est-à-dire
le gouvernement central à Pékin.
Jeff, donc au-delà de ces
mesures liberticides qu'on prend
un peu partout dans le monde
comme en Hongrie, parlons
maintenant des néonazis et
de ce qu'on peut dire à leur
sujet en lien avec la COVID-19.
- Bien oui, on parlait dans un
épisode plus tôt cette saison de
l'accélérationnisme, qui est un
courant particulièrement extrême
du néonazisme, qui prône
l'accélération de l'effritement
social, donc provoquer la chute
de la civilisation occidentale
par toutes sortes de moyens,
que ce soit des moyens
terroristes ou des actions
du genre. Eh bien, il y a
un rapport du SITE Intelligence
Group, qui est une entreprise
de renseignement privée,
qui surveille tout l'extrémisme
sur les réseaux sociaux, donc
pas seulement l'État islamique
mais les néonazis aussi.
Et ce qu'ils ont trouvé,
c'est que dans des forums privés
pour les gens, les néonazis
les plus particulièrement
extrémistes, on prône
d'utiliser la désinformation
à des fins d'accélérationnisme,
donc pour provoquer la chute
du gouvernement américain.
Et certains exemples qu'ils
donnent, c'est par exemple
distribuer des fausses affiches
dans des communautés juives
ou musulmanes disant aux gens :
bien, si vous éprouvez des
symptômes de COVID-19, allez
vous réfugier à la mosquée ou à
la synagogue. Donc, dans le but
de propager les taux d'infection
dans ces communautés-là.
On a aussi vu dans ce rapport-là
des néonazis mettre de l'avant
l'idée de propager dans les
réseaux sociaux des fausses
nouvelles, des fausses rumeurs
pour augmenter la confusion
chez la population. Et un des
exemples qu'on a évoqués,
c'était d'aller dans les...
d'aller dans les sections
"commentaires" des journaux
de propager des rumeurs comme
quoi l'armée serait sur le point
d'occuper le territoire, donc
aller dire : hé! j'ai entendu
mon cousin qui est dans l'armée
qui me dit que l'armée va
débarquer et occuper notre
ville. Et je ne dis pas
qu'il y a un lien, mais on a vu
des rumeurs comme ça circuler au
Québec il y a quelques semaines.
Il y avait des vidéos qui
circulaient qui disaient
que l'armée s'en venait
à Montréal, amenait des
véhicules militaires à Montréal.
Donc, faut faire très, très
attention quand on partage
des rumeurs comme ça parce qu'on
le sait pas, peut-être est-ce
que ça peut faire partie d'une
campagne de propagande des
courants les plus extrémistes
du web. Donc, vraiment faites
très, très, très attention
aux rumeurs.
- Oui. C'est ça, avant de
partager, si vous avez des
doutes, bien, pensez-y un peu
puis écrivez-nous, pourquoi pas,
aux Décrypteurs, pour qu'on y
rejette un petit coup d'oeil,
ça c'est important de le
rappeler également.
Moi ce qui a attiré mon
attention, bien, c'est entre
autres WhatsApp qui a sévi
contre les chaînes de messages.
WhatsApp, faut le comprendre,
pour ceux qui connaissent
moins ça, c'est un service
de messager crypté, privé,
qui appartient au groupe
Facebook. C'est pas mal
de monde ça, c'est entre
1,5 milliard et 2 milliards
d'utilisateurs actifs à travers
le monde. Et ce qui a été pris
comme décision du côté de
WhatsApp pour lutter contre
la désinformation, c'est limiter
les possibilités de partager
un même message plus de cinq
fois. Ce qu'il faut
comprendre, c'est que WhatsApp,
sur WhatsApp, les messages
se propagent assez rapidement
parce qu'il suffit de les
transmettre, c'est possible
plutôt de les transmettre
d'un seul coup à l'ensemble
de son carnet d'adresses.
Alors, on comprend que
c'est assez exponentiel très
rapidement. Alors, on a voulu
agir vite parce que c'est
à travers ces canaux-là que
la désinformation sur la
covid-19 s'est mise à circuler,
à circuler, à circuler à un
rythme assez effréné.
Et ça a déjà été fait ça pas
plus tard que l'été dernier
par WhatsApp, la même mesure,
en Inde, quand une fausse rumeur
avait occasionné bien tristement
la mort de 25 personnes.
Alors, on voit qu'il y en a qui
prennent ça au sérieux parmi les
grandes plates-formes, peut-être
pas assez au goût de certains,
mais il y a des mesures qui sont
mises de l'avant. On a vu que
YouTube, Twitter et Facebook
ont carrément retiré des
messages provenant du président
brésilien Jair Bolsonaro,
qui est lui-même, si on veut,
une personne qui doute fortement
de la sévérité et de la gravité
de la situation actuelle, alors
on a retiré ces messages-là pour
protéger la sécurité du public.
Et on a vu cette semaine aussi
YouTube s'attaquer aux vidéos
conspirationnistes qui lient
la 5G et le coronavirus.
Et même au Canada, il faut le
rappeler, il y a de l'argent,
des sommes additionnelles qui
ont été injectées cette semaine
par le gouvernement fédéral pour
lutter contre la désinformation.
Bref, on n'est pas les seuls
aux Décrypteurs à essayer
de faire changer les choses
et renverser la vapeur face
à ces informations qui nuisent
à l'intérêt public.
Jeff et Bouchra, c'était un
plaisir de vous voir et de vous
entendre. Je sais pas quand
est-ce...
- Plaisir partagé.
- Bien oui, je sais pas quand
est-ce qu'on va se revoir, mais
j'ai bien hâte, j'ai bien hâte
de vous serrer la pince ou à
tout le moins un petit coup
de coude.
- On se verra virtuellement
ici à tout le moins.
- C'est important pour respecter
la distanciation sociale.
Alors, à vous qui nous écoutez,
qui nous regardez, continuez
à nous suivre, à nous écrire
par courriel, hésitez pas à
faire comme les 26 000 personnes
qui ont joint jusqu'à maintenant
notre groupe Facebook, adhérez
aussi à notre infolettre qu'on
publie semaine après semaine.
Alors, au nom de toute l'équipe,
à la fois ceux que vous voyez
en ce moment sur votre écran et
ceux qui travaillent aussi avec
nous à nos côtés, je vous dis
salut, portez-vous bien,
prenez soin de vous. Au revoir.
Sous-titrage
Société Radio-Canada